[Musique]
aucune automaticité alors effectivement
énoncé comme ça on peut on peut supposer
qu'en fait on enlève un outil
démocratique est en fait c'est pas ça du
tout c'est plutôt revivifier redynamiser
ce système de pétitions qui existe en
france depuis la révolution
alors au moment de la révolution il y
avait jusqu'à 150 pétition par jour ce
qui était absolument gigantesque alors
que là par exemple depuis quelques
années les pétitions se comptent sur les
doigts des mains puisqu'elle a eu à
peine une vingtaine donc c'est un outil
un outil démocratique que nos
concitoyens en fait tu n'utilises pas
bien alors qu'ils vont beaucoup sur les
plates formes puisque vous pouvez avoir
des sur les plateformes un million de
millions de signatures donc l'idée
c'était de faire en sorte que ce système
là soit absolument mieux pris en compte
par notre pas nos concitoyens pour
dynamiser cet outil et faire en sorte
que à partir d'un certain nombre de
signataires donc pour avoir une
cohérence et pour avoir une
représentativité sur un sujet ceux ci
puissent aboutir à une proposition de
loi moi je pense fermement que il faut
qu'il faut étendre les droits de
pétitions que l'usagé qui en sera fait
sera d'autant plus large que les
citoyens courant dans des délais
raisonnables
la certitude que leur pétition était
prise en compte et qu'elles aboutissent
à un résultat quelconque ce qui est
importante et ja c'est que le résultat
de l'action pétitionnaires soit rapide
c'est à dire qu'on peut pas prôner à une
époque où on ne peut pas lancer une
pétition en attendant les résultats
doucement occasion après ou 18 mois
notre côté il faut que les citoyens qui
signent une pétition ils connaissent les
règles c'est à dire que la règle du
sénat qu'il paraît pas parfait dans ce
cas choisi la commission c'est en fait
de laisser à la discrétion marie mercier
l'a très bien dit c'est à dire il n'y a
pas d'automaticité mais pour autant ça
veut pas dire que le sénat ne va pas
discriminer et il va rejeter toutes les
pétitions
pour qu'il ait plus d'impact
effectivement il faut déjà une forme de
communication de cet outil que les
citoyens puissent se l'approprier
parce qu'il ya bien sûr ya l'idée
d'inscrire un texte de loi mais il ya
aussi la possibilité créer une mission
de contrôle pour réviser les lois qui
existent déjà ou pour évaluer l'action
du gouvernement où les politiques
publiques
une fois qu'il y aura un sujet ensuite
celui ci a livré devant le bureau du
sénat à condition de parler les cent
mille signatures
le bureau du sénat évaluerez l'intérêt
la recevabilité voir si ça ne s'entre
choquent pas avec des travaux
parlementaires en cours fils à la
conférence
il pourrait à ce moment là la prévoir
dans son dans son agenda
donc l'intérêt des pétitions c'est c'est
vraiment de faire en sorte que nous
citoyens s'intéressent davantage à nos
travaux aux travaux parlementaires et
que finalement notre démocratie
représentative
donc que ce soit guy mois nous puissions
ray de dans une part de démocratie
participative
mais avec une forme de contrôle pour que
ceux ci soient cohérents et représente
vraiment ce que demandent nos nous
citoyens français
les pétitions et roquelaure peut
fonctionner ces derniers temps j'en ai
deux en tête
geslin pétition de quatre associations
concernant l'action du gouvernement pour
lutter contre le réchauffement
climatique qui est une pétition qui à
qui a atteint des signes intérieurs de
signature considérables et qui aboutit
donc à une action en justice
perdu d'ailleurs par le gouvernement et
qui est en voie de continuer et puis je
pense à la pétition sur la loi littoral
qui est pétition pour obtenir aussi 850
mille signatures et qui a permis de
peser force mais les décisions qui
pourraient être prises et qui seront
peut être prises d'ailleurs lors d'un
loin climat concernant le littoral dox
ça veut dire quoi ces deux pétitions qui
a fonctionné c'était pas des pétitions
de vendée
des institutions et c'était des
pétitions fait par des associations au
casier ou par des ou par des plateformes
numériques et l heure fonctionner parce
que leur impact a été très largement
diffusé et que leur impact a abouti dans
les faits un certain nombre de décisions
assez rapidement en tout cas à une
action de pression qui a permis à
certain nombre de décisions assez
rapidement l'intérêt en fait du
président du sénat puisque lui c'est lui
qui porte cette proposition de changer
notre règlement c'est de faire mieux
connaître le sénat de faire mieux
connaître nos travaux c'est quelque
chose que le président a à coeur de
faire en sorte que le sénateur sont
attendus connu on connaît mieux les
députés parce que peut-être il s'exprime
davantage mais nous notre rôle est
souvent absolument méconnu donc c'est
sûr que très peu de gens savaient qu'ils
pouvaient déposer une pétition au sénat
et puis surtout elle n'aboutissait pas
parce qu'elle arrivait directement à la
commission quelquefois l arrivée chez le
défenseur des droits elles étaient
adressées aux ministres et puis elle
devenait caduc et puis finalement elles
n'aboutissent à rien du tout donc il
était vraiment très très important de
moderniser cet outil qui est un vrai
outil démocratique
aujourd'hui deux plateformes numériques
comme la vase ou comme charles power ou
même agir pour l'environnement où notre
affaire à tous en des capacités
numériques de faire connaître leur
pétition qu'ils soient au final
supérieure à celle qu'un du sénat est
donc là il ya un effort à faire de notre
côté aussi pour faire connaître
l'existence de cette possibilité p6
pétitionnaires par l'intermédiaire du
sénat dont il ya un effort à faire à ce
niveau là au niveau de l'information
mais il ya aussi un effort comme ça très
très lisible pour le citoyen
c'est-à-dire qu'il n'ait pas
l'impression que en fait c'est à la
discrétion au final des sénateurs qui
sont la représentation effectivement
qu'il a choisi bien entendu mais qu'ils
sont une nouvelle fois la représentation
d'une démocratie représentative